des mesures supplémentaires pour les
lycées franciliens valérie pécresse a
proposé des aménagements possibles pour
les cantines si le lycée reste en rouge
complète
nous proposons des demies jauge adapté
pour les cantines avec la possibilité de
commander pour la moitié des élèves des
paniers repas et de les faire déjeuner
soit dans des classes qui seront ensuite
ultérieurement nettoyées par les agents
de la région soit dans des locaux
temporaires des recrutements d'agents
ont eu lieu depuis septembre 240 en
supplément et 200 autres en remplacement
d'agents malades ou qu'à contacter aussi
la région offre la possibilité à chaque
lycée d'avoir recours à l'intérim
autre point important la poursuite du
déploiement du numérique nous avons
décidé en septembre
au vu de la situation qui se dégrade est
de commander 70 mille ordinateurs
supplémentaires
ils seront à destination des élèves de
première et terminale qui n'ont pas
d'équipement personnel
dix mille ordinateurs supplémentaires
ont été commandés pour les élèves de bts
et de classes préparatoires le dépistage
au sein des établissements a aussi été
pensé
on va faire une proposition au lycée de
mise à disposition de cent mille tests
antigénique dans les lycées les lycées
qui le souhaitent bien sûr ces tests
pourraient être réalisées par les
infirmières scolaires des tests qui
pourront être faits sur les équipes
enseignantes et les lycéens avec une
autorisation parentale